[Musique]
fondamentalement je ne vois pas la
raison d'une telle réforme est
singulièrement pas en ces temps où nous
avons plus besoin que jamais de
diplomatie regardez cet exemple lorsque
le président de la république va en
visite officielle moi j'aime arrive de
il m'est arrivé de l'accompagner dans
les visites d'état le président a
véritablement besoin de toute la
compétence de ses agents de ses
collaborateurs diplomatique pour savoir
à qui on s'adresse sur quel sujet on va
s'exprimer quand le président a
rencontré le président poutine il
fallait qu'il ait des notes bien bien
forte bien bien importante et bien
renseigné pour pouvoir anticiper
discuter négocier en tous les cas ici au
sein même de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense je crois que
c'est un avis unanime et du reste notre
commission va rédiger un rapport j'ai
désigné plusieurs sénateurs à porter qui
enquêtent et qui sont actuellement en
train d'auditionner pour donner son avis
puisque pour l'instant n'a pas été
consulté alors c'est vrai que ça relève
du décret mais je pense qu'une telle
transformation sur un corps aussi
essentiel à la vie de l'état mériterait
au moins un débat alors nous ne créerons
par la rédaction d'un rapport qui sera
discuté ici
[Musique]
indiscutablement je pense que si cette
réforme est mise en oeuvre comme c'est
vrai cela est prévu de le faire ce sera
pour conséquence de diminuer l'influencé
que la france peut exercer parce
qu'effectivement elle enverra des
diplomates moins chevronnés moins
habitués à la pratique des relations
internationales et cela aura
immédiatement des conséquences la
diplomatie devient un
secteur très compliqué très difficile
nous sommes partout dans le monde en
concurrence avec les grandes puissances
et avec des états qui eux font beaucoup
plus d'efforts que nous en matière
diplomatique
je pense par exemple à l'allemagne qui
investit massivement dans sa diplomatie
nous chaque année nous nous battons pour
que les crédits ne se ne diminue pas
trop je pense que si en plus on retire
des compétences à nos agents
diplomatiques
ce sera certainement un mauvais coup
pour notre rayonnement
[Musique]